it's a pleasure to be here in California
you cannot imagine how nice to get up in
the morning and see the blue sky
especially if you are coming from
Cornell so I went for weather shock
today I'm going to talk about part of my
research work I'll try to introduce it
in a broader picture of what electronic
systems are today in what they are going
to be I will go through a quick outline
of my talk I will start with a
motivation that actually relates to the
application that translates into what is
Nani doing in Switzerland in general
second I will talk about technological
innovations part of that relates to
material that's more of tutorial nature
but then that will help to show you what
type of work we have been doing with
emerging technologies especially with
design methods and tools for this
emerging technology and then we'll get
into another part of the talk in which I
will talk about the majority paradigm in
logic synthesis so from emerging devices
will see the tools we'll see general
methods and eventually we will see how
these methods are applicable to standard
CMOS so we can somehow back full circle
to see how research in electronics
enables models and algorithm computer
science that eventually is used to
design electronic system and then I will
conclude so just to start and to give
the big picture we live in a connected
world talk about the Internet of Things
or the internet of everything and we
talk about basically ubiquitous
computing and communications systems
that have to be autonomous terms of
energy autonomous in terms of
intelligence damos driving you have
mainly four type of components you have
the hardware the software but then you
have sensors and equators and many years
ago when I was
in the VLSI class we were focusing
mainly on the electronics then we went
into the hardware software code design
and then software became dominant in
system design but there is an entire
dimension that relates a cui to sense of
actuators and how we interface the
computing to the rest of the world
and finally what we do have to be
reasonably low cost because they are
consumers at the end of the line so what
you have to design has something that's
applicable so what I've been doing in
Switzerland a part of having fun with my
research I started about ten years ago a
program called nano tyrannous eh worse
eh stand for Switzerland which is a
program that leads to using and foster
the use of electronic and informatics
computer science technology for the
design of systems in the domain of
health and the environment
this relates to a program that I got
directly funded by the consideration and
I am very proud of having set this up
because I do think that it's a duty for
advanced countries to invest in Health
and Environment and one of the best
investment is in technologies for Health
and Environment because they reduce
costs and so they are benefits to all so
this program has been fairly large just
to give you an idea the run rate is 30
millions a year and as Swiss franc today
it's more or less like a dollar so we
had 150 projects funded because that is
not my pet baby where I have people
working for me I basically manage this
across BIOS institution and the idea is
that when you have an objective which is
defined with Nicole and approved by a
body this objective has to involve
various aspects of science in this case
typically have the same thing the
computer science and electronics part
and you have to create a team so overall
food is nine years of the projects about
1,300 researchers were involved then
more than 300 pieces has been founded so
it's been a fairly big thing to make the
point that Electronics sensing and
computer science is important in
Switzerland that's a picture of
Switzerland with the lakes and you can
see the mountains and I've always been a
fan of grass so you see the grass would
show as note the places where the
research is done and you can see Duke
and Lausanne as a big note that probably
to be politically correct they're being
drawn to have exactly the same diameter
and the and the edges represent the
communication bandwidth between the
nodes that is you know the joint
students joined grants that have been
enabled by this program and actually as
a side effect beside having it fairly I
would say noble objective one by-product
has been increase in the cooperation
between the various institution not only
the big one but also the small ones that
get attached to it and therefore
creating an entire global national
effort and to some extent if you want to
put in perspectives in the United States
people connect the Mississippi with the
Missouri to make the biggest river in
the world and here you put together
people from Zurich from Lausanne inform
other places you really create a very
big force from intellectual and
scientific standpoint well people who
like you well what happens to that part
of Switzerland where where there is no
circles are these your enemies no athle
a lots of mountains there that's the
southern part of Switzerland is occupied
by mountains and so that's where some
experiments in the environment are
happening but we researchers typically
do not leave or operate so give you some
examples I'll give you a couple of
examples of things that we've been doing
it you know one example is telemedicine
so monitoring for example chronic
patients at the distance and you know
there's an entire family of things like
non-involved non-invasive monitors to
measure heart rate oxygen saturation
blood pressure
a queasy device done by a startup
company by my last Stanford PhD student
who actually has made a couple of
company blood intrapreneurs spirit down
to the consideration and these devices
actually can be very helpful to be very
inexpensive and now they sell them to
hospitals for doing remote monitoring
now of course the challenging thing
comes when you want to do invasive
sensing when you really want to measure
metabolites more molecules like glucose
lactate cholesterol because these
measures have to be continuous time they
have to be calibrated in temperature in
pH so the systems are actually much more
complex then you have Wireless
challenges how you would transmit the
information for something which is on
the body or in the body to the outside
how you make the information secure and
so on and how you provide energy also to
this type of devices I hear just one
example of an implanted computing system
that we have done this is kind of a
tablet it's basically once a meter
square s footprint and three millimeters
in height you can see four sensors at
the surface and this ketchup which shows
how it's organized you have the
samething layer on the top we have an IC
in the middle and you have a coil at the
bottom because the system aggregates the
energy from the Rabi frequency field
which is transmitted because the system
is for implant is not put into students
they accuse me of doing this thing on
graduate students I don't do that but
this has been a pre if the picture shows
the implant inside an animal and this
security has been done we have done a
lot of experimentation and this picture
he actually gives you a different
perspective of what is an impulse
response so there is a mouse which is
really moving with these devices inside
this is the response to an impulse which
is a shot of paracetamol and this is the
reaction okay-y past the most because we
are looking at anesthetics and
controlling patient under anesthesia so
this is one of the experimenters we have
well
somebody will tell me well you know the
picture there the green line is not
actually one - and exponential there's
lots of noise in there and my reply to
that is yes you know try to tell a mouse
after a shot keep quiet don't run too
much and you know you can criticize my
box so this is one type of activity it
is just one example of the many
applications that we have looked at for
electronics in medicine and now let me
show you something about the environment
this has been done actually by
colleagues of ours in Zurich so we start
from this picture the Matterhorn
just the landmark for Switzerland and
with the blue sky that was probably
photoshopped and that's because it's so
blue looks like California but this is
actually the environment as you like it
to be and this is reality reality is
that there's life there are Rock Falls
there is a construction up there that's
not going to last 50 years because
sooner or later it will come down and
there are our fault attack we can harm
villages and towns down below because
Switzerland is mainly in an Alpine
environment in their communities who
live there so this project has been
related to checking how works how ice
moves very often there are rocks that
are placed on top of ice so you can see
the mountains this is not too much of a
civil area even though it's not too far
from them and the instrumentation that
used many ways of acquiring information
it relates to measuring the speed of the
rocks speed that sometimes is as high as
one centimeter a month so that's a quick
look something high but it's very slow
so in order to do that you need to get
Road GPS signals you have to transmit
that you need to have supercomputing to
detect this one variation and then you
have to put the positions and the speeds
into a geological model which will give
you the stresses and will give you the
probability of having poles and in order
to do this again there's the sensing
part and then there is a networking part
because the picture on the right degree
shows values
Asian that they're being placed in
various positions in Afridi between out
the channel so they use for transmitting
information finally to a place which is
the one on the right where you can
funnel information out on the internet
because in those places where it's that
I remote typically there is not much
access for humans okay so some key
points to remember out of this
introduction electronic systems multiple
dimensions so it's not just about
designing computer and this is what I
tell all the students because I think
that E is a very attractive field to be
in
there's just the computing the storage
then there is this entire transducing
relating to the rest of the environment
and of course there are new compute
computing paradigms that are on the
horizon you need in order to do this
deal with new materials devices with
circuits because it's not just about
enhancing CMOS but actually looking at
how you can integrate together the
computing part and the sensing part
and using the benefit of VLSI technology
to get part that we can be cheap enough
to be used and eventually all these
motivates new design methods new tools I
come from the EBA tradition electronic
design automation and sometimes I'm told
well you know this is a dead boot
because you can buy things well sure
that is for if you want to design the
electronics of the past but if you want
to look at the future there's lots of
things that need to be done that means
that this I want to come into the second
part I want to briefly review something
in technology to get to some
technological innovation that I think
relevant so everybody today talks about
nano devices because standard
run-of-the-mill CMOS is occurring the
nano dimensions and those killing
geometries are still effective people
can argue about more life more louis
alive for that for ages but reality is
that there is still a lot of interest
and if ever
the downscaling of the technology will
not be economically attractive we will
still have to do it because we want to
have the most possible computing power
after that machine because computing
power means really general power for
understanding the world and also
controlling them so today we basically
with two technologies that are around
the target which are the FinFETs as well
as the fda sy the fully depleted and so
on but they also some emerging
nanotechnologies and it's important to
see how they are placed in my view
enhanced CMOS is there to stay because
of the investment that we have done in
the fab lines you know the seven nano no
the 5 nano nodes are basically panel on
the way if you look at road maps aqua
this is a road but coming from iMac you
see this transition from FinFETs
to lateral or horizontal nanowires to
vertical analyze and then this lights
actually fade out because you go into
the future beyond you know these five
have any arrival but my believe is that
many interesting technologies one SD
nano wise which is the closest one
because as manipulation to FinFET the
upcoming one after that is the carbon
nanotube inhere and preaching to the
converted about carbon nanotubes is
extremely important and then there's
also the electronics that to the mental
to dimension electronics which is also
extremely important as a technology for
us the important thing is to understand
what are the differentiator and what are
the common denominators among these
technologies because if you want to
design with them you have to understand
the various angle for designing it and
where you would have some leverage now
for those of you who are not familiar
with nano wires and on a wire adjust a
thin part of silicon that can have a
cylindrical shape on the right you will
see another wire with the gate the gate
is called an all-around gate and being
all around athletes better that what you
have on a thin thread where you have the
gate on
trick dimensions because you have a
better electrostatic control of the
device and what you want optimized in
the end in this device is
goal I on over IRA so because you want
to have devices that deliver current and
so can be fast at the same time you want
to have little leakage when the device
is off now how this relates to a FinFET
well you see a FinFET on the left you
will see a set of nano wires on the
right and also it then is the FinFETs
get smaller and they get they will get
probably more round and so they will
evolve into this even though the
advantage of nano wires is that you can
actually construct them in a way in
which you have multiple filaments one on
top of each other this is actually a
picture from our labs of things that we
have and the idea is that you
potentially have many transistors that I
am serious and so according to how many
of these wires you would connect you
have the equivalent of the low current
medium current high current drive as we
have in libraries that we use today
now q2 there is of course getting this
nano wires vertically but it's a much
more difficult beast to to handle it
because the fabrication is more complex
for the vertical otherwise but you can
think that it's very attractive to have
planes in which you have the vertical
nano wires as it's done for example in
flashes today and and and this in
parallel with vias and having therefore
some sort of an arrangement this picture
comes from a group in Toulouse and there
are other groups as we around the world
that have been working on these
technologies the CNT is you know again
I'm preaching to the convertor the
scientists the carbon nanotubes have the
main advantage that the material itself
has much higher mobility so for small
devices you can push more current you
get things that are faster that would
consume less energy and then there are
ways of dealing with scientists like you
know than here at Stanford that allow
you low temperature processes so that we
can do stacking of value flavor let
levels of devices attack which was
remarkable that here the first sort of
nano computer with nanotubes was
realized and into a really effective
function application I have a citation
of people involving their there are not
all of them because I don't remember all
the name but this was a major
achievement the next step in my opinion
if you look at technology is to use the
flat Tronics 2d electronics and this is
again on top of the sketch from a
transistor this has been lots of work in
Lausanne by a colleague of mine and
relief with mauritania missiles IDs MOS
- and this material actually can lead
you to doing n-type mainly transistors
that also have a very high ion over I
off but again we have to put the thing
in perspective we have fin FET today we
have nano wire small s today CMT's in
order to develop on a large scale will
require a few years here where at least
10 years ahead of having devices that
are competitive because these devices
typically with this material also fairly
big that is are today in the order of 1
micron and people are looking at ways of
scaling them down so it takes time to
get things to to work properly now
coming to innovations we have worked for
quite a while in on this double gate
silicon nanowire transistor what's the
idea is that you have done a wise and it
has two gates to control them what they
do control they control the Schottky
Junction that you would have an
interface so by controlling them you can
create devices that are either P or M so
you have a transistor that has two gates
and therefore you have a bubble which is
controllable and you can get the pivot
or you can get the in fact the this is
also called electrostatic doping because
you don't need to dope the device to
differentiate the P from an M you can
get that possible runtime of at
configuration time so you have ways of
also building a few days but the concept
is again that you're bringing the
configuration at the device level and
that's along the line that everything in
computing has been by soft means to
bring configuration to do computing and
you can do that
at this
for this type of devices every more
importantly is that you have a device
which basically is an atomic comparator
because the P is accurate on Wendy when
a gate is low so two zeros will make it
come back on you conduct and the end
when two ones are there so you have a
comparator so you can build access a pre
in a very very simple way the simplest
is good to put a resistor on top of it
so these are pictures aqueous devices
that have been realized I think the
picture down there is quite nice because
we can see in green the nano wires and
you see one gate in purple remember that
silicon is great extremely boring but
Photoshop and we can make the things
more attractive and actually can make
your color to think this you get another
color this is stuck with the second
level on top of that how bigger this you
know we can up we do them with 20 nano
in diameters they are fairly long so I
don't say that these devices are at we
competitive with the existing think
that's because they expect but it's an
interesting concept to elaborate and by
the way there is no need to put the
pilate gate on both sides you can put it
on one side there is concurrent work
that's been done by colleagues addressed
and that we use just one polarity gate
on one side of the devices a cuidar more
tricks that you can do with this you can
separate the two gates and if we build
the device that it has three gates
overall and why would you do it because
in here you can build by looking at the
various combination a device that can be
on as a P or then you can have a device
which is off that has a low threshold or
high threshold why is that important
it's important because we think circuit
typically use mobility devices for the
critical path where you have to be fast
and a high VT where you have to use
device you tend to be slower where you
need to save power and at we this can be
done for example after design by
configuring the devices or even in a
during dynamic way now interesting
enough this concept of doing
controllable switching can be applied to
some other materials this is a picture
of
work that we did with IMAX about one
year ago and here it shows another kind
of strange material which is a vault
from tombstone this I night and this
comes in flakes you will see their flake
you will see the controls and you will
see on the right side in blue the kind
of the N Mo's type of currents on the
left at PMO's kind of current of course
this is again purely a research that
still needs advancement the level of the
currents and the order of tens of
microns so it's it's a little bit low
and also the voltage are a little bit
too high while with the nanowire luckily
we can have devices to switch very well
between zero and one balls with really
symmetric configuration this type of
research will evolve as we will be able
acqui to grow this material on top of
the wafers and that will be back to our
manufacturing process but anyhow what's
the messaging here the messages that you
can have various emerging technologies
that implement a switch controlled by a
comparator and this can be done with
none of us can be done with carbon
nanotubes there's being work by various
group that has shown the control
polarity of these devices this is a
sketch of the batteries of which is a
Samsung device that mixes silicon with
graphene nano relays also can camp as
part of this paradigm so the key point
in here you know these are multi-agency
so this offer enhanced functionality
they can be done with various materials
without with various shapes there are
various levels of maturity of this type
of technology and they tend to increase
the so called computational density you
have a cui more intelligence per device
within one system the atomic operation
is a comparator and you have this device
level programmability that can be for
example interesting in designing new
generation LPGA's
so next point is how to design with this
emerging technologies just a few ideas
there so I concentrate on this control
polarity devices and if you have in CMOS
you can implement very well- unit
functions because the structure of CMOS
is such that any fundamental gate is
more evening better which is more
complex if you want to implement this
with these technologies you best give
fix the polarity of the devices and you
have the P equivalent network on the top
the end at the bottom and it's very
similar but the interesting part for
using this type of devices is for doing
this goal by net functions we know very
well the XOR comparators parties don't
come up that knifing CMOS just because
of this nature of this input that can
mean also complemented and with this
technology have a way of treating
because you can come in on the p on the
end of these also you have kind of any
variant for free how you design with
this this is kind of a gate array of
these devices and this is AK with the
abstraction you remember the stick
diagrams from the VLSI here we have the
green dumbbells which Starlin otherwise
when you have the 2 colors for the
various types of gate the de red and
blue you have to align them as in case
of CMOS but you also have to come up
with arrangements so that the polarity
gate can be contacted nicely keep in
mind one thing that if you try to use a
divisor there's four inputs the local
wiring has to be done in a smart way
otherwise you lose everything in the
context so what you can do with this and
this is actually portable across various
technologies you can actually arrange
the transistors Weaver topology so that
you have a master cell that's like a
site inside a gate array that then can
be configured in such way that you have
an end and the nor will be similar to
demand by changing the ground with the
VDD or you can have an extra so the same
master cell with the four terms they
start killing them at various primitives
and that we can be used with a different
slightly different to do the maths
or a minority how do you abstract it
when you look at the logic you know in
most cases when we took we talk about
logic design we use the binary decision
diagram so that we where proposed by
Randy Bryan who proved all the
properties that are based on the idea
that you have a function in your
expresses as two part the cofactors that
depend on a variable and in the
complemented Bible why because the
variable activates the switch switching
gear here we are doing comparison so
what we have we have comparator
activators which so the abstraction
would be the fact that you have two
variables coming into node and the fact
that they're equal or they are not equal
will make you branch to different sub
trees again the fact that two variables
are equal or not equal I could create an
orthonormal basis on which you can do an
expansion so in a simple way you could
say well I have a diagram representing
my function I'm what is the
representation it's at max activated by
a comparator you can do it by transistor
and C was like this or you can do it by
a basic cell like that this would be a
way to realize the function may not be
eventually the best way of doing it
because if these three is fairly deep
then you have many transistor in serious
so that will affect of course the
performance but why we do that well
first because this Diane which we call a
queen BVDs because there's a big
conditional binary decision diagrams are
kind of a natural way for expressing
this technology but also they are a very
good way to represent computational
blocks that do arithmetic where you have
comparison XOR that then can be
implemented in any technologies and that
we they are very nice properties about
these diagrams because they abstract
well functions like addition and like
the majority function in a very nice way
this picture here shows a majority of
seven inputs that can be seen as the
nesting of values but
and this type of data structure bring
this out what is majority majority is
basically a function that if you have
three inputs will tell you it's two if
at least two input are two a majority is
the sign of an odd number of inputs
because on again it could be undecided
so it is a very important function that
indicate for example as a complemented
way that's called minority is used in
for building two basic address the basic
other cells use minority I like to make
a few key points before I move on the
design methods and tool for multi gate
transistors are important and because
they allow a compact realization of
functions like XOR parties and parts of
by innate functions that appear a lot
within the computational part of the
chips look at lots of trips that do for
example signal processing do image
analysis they have a lot of our
hit-making there lots of blocks that
very often have to be customized and
that benefits for to that we can
optimize these by net functions smart
wiring is extremely important so
arrangement so that the wiring is done
in a nice way
and the next point that will make me do
the link between the lexical part and
the computer science part of this talk
is that this new technology show that
there are functions that are extremely
important in design that basically are
the comparison and the majority function
we and I say we I see myself as a
designer who as as I have designed a lot
with CMOS we are fairly often biased by
the fact of thinking that eventually we
have to think in terms of nan snores and
inverters which is actually our typical
thing in which for your reason and
there's no reason why we think of this
we can actually think of different ways
of expressing the logic that we use this
blocks majority in comparison which by
the way are the bread and butter for
doing others and multiplies
why I am focusing on this because I
think the problem was creating random
logic finite state machines which is
good enough for us it's kind of solved
by the problem of pushing data paths in
an efficient way it's a problem that
from a design point of view it's open so
this leads to the last part of my talk
which is about the majority paradigm in
logic synthesis so why majority why
think in terms of majority because
majority logic has a sound mathematical
foundation I will show that later on in
my talk but you can make claims about
using majority that cannot be done with
other types of representation which is
basically the opportunity of designing
logic part the faster more performing
consuming less power and so on
majority functions can be used to
implement rational functions social
functions are very important for
neuromorphic computing and at we if you
design your Bostic chips they are very
few aquaeden i to my knowledge there are
no specialized tools that help to design
it most of the work the logic design has
to be done custom a so this is actually
extremely important and then the
majority is also a computation
abstraction for some emerging
technologies like spin wave quantum
cellular automata why because everything
that kind of wave oriented eventually
relates to implementation where this
wave path will collide and will
interfere in a positive or a negative
way if the design is digital that if you
look for 1 and 0 then you look at the
constructive or destructive interference
of these patterns which is the majority
itself an inversion is done by giving
enough distances for the wave so that
the wave will be inverted at the right
point resistive ramps can also be seen
as implementing the
a majority function and it's very
important because you can use this to
design resistive Ram cells to implement
logic functions and therefore to realize
blocks of this called processing within
memory Pio and also many systems that
are used for data acquisition for again
the case of health of the environment
have to deal with lots of large data
sets and also from the hardware point of
view it's interesting to have means of
acquiring information it's a great
values where majority plays role so how
much of this is new well if you look
actually at last book of don't you find
this sentence that majority is probably
the most important turn operation in the
entire universe so it's actually very
inspiring to start doing some research
work and find out that Donna thought
about this 20 years ago inequity is true
that there was a lot of work or majority
that was done in the 60s works about
mathematical properties but the use of
these paradigms to design as really
never put into practice because logic
physics
synthesis came out with different types
of abstractions so again why majority
logic if you take a majority gate and
you're writing as just a logic function
of three variables a B and C you can see
that this is a just a generalization of
the end or if you set a bit to zero you
get the end if we set a bit to 1 you get
the or and so we are back to the same
concept that I was showing you before or
having gates that can be programmed from
a higher level that could be soft like
that could be firmer to make them to
give them a specific configuration then
the next point is that majority logic
will unlock optimization that are not
applying before I will show you by
example and our we'll show you why that
is from a formal point of view so that's
an example if you
have under logic and your possibilities
are just to rearrange this endow
operator this dysfunction yet can be
optimized like this while if you map
into majority will become much smaller
now you can act well sure that's funny
you screw it that smaller but then you
have to map it into logic gates and so
in the end you're going back to the same
thing so you know because if you take
this function and you take a library I'm
taking the generally prime C and C which
is the public library then you can say
well this is the these are the two
representation I map this into the ends
of the inverters I get this necklace I
met the other one I get a smaller
necklace like we look the area and the
delay and areas are pretty much better
for the first implementation and the
delay is the same but then I could say
well there's a missing part in this
gentleman there's actually not the
minority gate which is a gate it appears
in many libraries and it's not that
complicated so if I add the minority 3
gate which is the majority inverted in
the output then I will get this
realization that a tree has smaller and
smaller like so this is what happens on
one example so let's try to generalize
this so we want to have good and
scalable models for manipulating
majority logic the idea is to use
majority inversion as a representation
so the state of the art today in logic
synthesis to use the end or inverter
graphs this has been evolution from the
first models using logic synthesis by
Braille tone by traveling in the puritan
project and in Mis si yes but this
exactly what is use that then it's based
on a traditional boolean actions what we
want to do is as we use a different
abstraction what you call mix which are
not Russian fighter planes but its
majority inverter graphs and that has an
Associated algebra which is boolean so
what is a graph like this it's a simple
abstraction you have a graph to make
things simple I keep my
jority of three so you have no that
represent majority and then you have
edges developers and dependencies you
can have bubbles bubbles would be the
inversions that you may have
well this in this talk I talk only about
majority free all this can be extended
to majority five seven and so on there
is the related theory which is available
and after which impart is fairly new and
we are proper post so what are the
properties of these images first that
all endo invert the eight graphs can be
mapped into energies why because of
course if you have an Ender or an order
that corresponds to a majority gate
where an input has been fixed so this is
a more general representation and how
you manipulate well you can actually
determine some axioms that define
majority starting from basic principles
without having to go for engine source
based on a few property like community
VT well if you have to vote it doesn't
matter you know when you vote but it
matters that what is the count there is
the majority property which is extremely
important that if two people agree out
of tree they win no matter what if two
people disagree is the third person wins
because the two an aquiline and then
there is a social dividend distributive
agree but there's another property which
is extremely important which is the
inverter propagation that is in a graph
you can get the bubbles float and that
we this is more general than inverter
propagation at which Xers can propagate
who majority so you can imagine a graph
where you have the two major
constituents the majority gate and X
goes and as we somehow said in loose
terms this to operate or commute that is
you can shift access before and after
the majority it is important well in
some case it's very important because if
you use advanced technologies that
allows you to do inversion in some place
or not like for example in the case of
qca you have a specific price that you
pay for in Versalles then it's important
to reduce this number of bubbles that
you have in the gas and it can use the
property that this can float back
for now the finest actions well you can
prove that this algebra is a boolean
algebra and you have equities to
specific properties this is the only
theoretical slide that I have in here
that the boolean algebra with this
action as I've shown before is both
sound and complete what does it mean if
a formalities and mick can be derived
from the axioms then it's valid and
vice-versa each valid formula is derive
a ball from the basic axiom or a
combination of this axiom that can give
the transformation rules so what does
this mean in practice this means that if
you are designing a system where you
have majority inversion the system has a
reach ability property so assume you
have a circle then you have a
configuration this is the connection of
the values part and assume that here you
have the best implementation of the
circuit then there is a path from A to B
so there's a way of reaching one part
from the other this is extremely
important it does not solve the problem
of how to find the path the problem per
se is still intractable and be something
but you know that there is a path which
is important because one we're going to
get better and better computer in the
future and in doing this exhaustive
enumeration may be important to find the
best solution and second is that you may
focus on circuit that are small enough
for which you can achieve at with the
optimal solution and get out of yours
conversely you can show that other
representations that I use today like an
inverter graphs and other models of
logic functions that are not really
functions but a diagrams where values
function are connected together do not
have this which should be a property so
no matter how much power you throw in
then you will not get possibly the
optimal so eventually tools that are
designed with today's technologies will
not get better as computer will get
faster but they may get stuck in slow
clock so what you do in practice you
know here you have transformation rules
that then can be combined and this act
we can be
used to do things like minimizing the
area that he relates to minimizing the
size of the make the performance which
is the depth and the power which relate
to the switching activity you may tell
me well but these are only indicators
that now how the circuit is done but
wait until I show you the experimental
results I assure you that this could be
very good guidelines to improve on
circuits optimizing so how would you do
the size optimization well there are
some transformations that are helpful if
you can apply the majority rules you
take away one node if you can apply the
associativity the distributive rule also
you can kick away one node if you do it
from right to left if you're looking for
that you know again with majority you
can reduce one level with a sensitivity
or distributivity you can reduce one
level and all depends on what is the
valuable it arrives last of course you
have to have a circuit you have to look
at what is the depth and of course it's
variable has related to a signal that
arrives last you want that to pass
through fewer stages and so you can use
this rule to restructure your graphs
now what about applying this experiments
to others okay this is the experiment I
don't claim that I design this to do
others there are better ways of doing
others that are known for others of
reasonable sizes but simply thing to see
that if you start from another that
looks like a ripple carry adder that has
a huge delay then after you can reduce
the number of levels by finding a
structure which is reminiscent of a
carry look ahead adder in an automatic
way and here are examples done on values
that establish where this type of
techniques will lead you from and
unoptimized structure to a structure
that is reminiscent again of a CLA that
has at least the same depth as a CLA may
be different does this work all the time
no because again I have the rich ability
and I apply your rules I may not apply
the right who's I cannot do the look
ahead in all possible cases look ahead
into sir
in terms of transformations so there are
examples in which I don't get something
which is the optimal result but it's a
step forward so some experiments done
with it I will show you two type of
experiments the first one is done just
on regular benchmarks that can try to
compare the size of the diagrams and the
logic and the second one is on place and
route chips because I really want to
show that the technique is useful in
practice after having them physical
design so here we have a space where you
have size depth and switching activity
to relate to power red is the color of
stem for this vessel as I said I keep
the same color and blue is Berkeley and
the BDD betas are pre-built get coming
from the work of seals kits armor so I
put gold because I don't know exactly
what is the color that they use the
timers but the result is that basically
MIG in IGS which is birthday compare in
terms of area and and switching
activities but this technique that we do
20% back in terms of that then you tell
me well I don't care about the depth the
graph I have a library I want to see the
thing after place and route so this is
the further set of experiment that we
have on signal so we take a 22 nano CMOS
technology with a library and then we do
the experiments in this way we add the
benchmarks and we run them through a
commercial synthesis or logic synthesis
and physical design we save the results
then we take the same bench press we run
them through the tools that map into
majority they do some optimization and
then you go again for this commercial
tools so that with the same library you
do the logic synthesis and physical
design and these are the results that
you get in aggregate you basically have
a reduction of 15% of the speed of the
delay with a reduction which is small in
terms of area and switching activity the
script wall
set up for optimizing the delay so
that's what we get but at least it shows
that we are not losing into in a area or
power now and of course the circuits
were formally verified to make sure that
we actually we're doing the right thing
one can argue then will it take a very
well-structured circuit you know like
for example a 32-bit divisor and see if
this would work so this was done on a
different library because that was what
we get available so we have the
behavioral part we have things written
with MIG s this is just a very long
rewriting or off the graph and here you
will see that you have the Iliad laying
get counts and the delay goes down again
by more or less fifteen percent than how
you look at that an arien gate count
goes down so as we disapprove that this
type of technology can help in reducing
significantly the delay of offices which
after having done the mapping to 12-hour
now getting back to the general picture
this is about CMOS so these techniques
that were originally thought for
emerging technologies are they good for
this emerging technologies or not well
no because it is very hard to prove
because when you talk about this
emerging technologies there are no
benchmarks that you can compare against
that's why I quit the strongest
benchmarks are the one by going back to
the symbols that we know very well
because we can compare but it's
important to know that you know majority
can abstract very well devices like
screen waves and spin transfer talk
devices well as you see a we have an
arrangement work with dynamic on these
technologies they as we do the devices
we do the tools and we help a Mac to
understand how this device is once
connected together will perform and of
course also this applies very well to
resistive Ram that we do implement the
majority function of the two electrodes
on the side and the previous state so
you can see a resistive Ram as a finite
state machine with one of the simples
being complimented
now some results on the on this you know
I don't want you to read this table
which you're extremely boring the only
thing is the bottom line in the circle
that shows up with our techniques that
we do better with wafer timing for these
spin wave devices done at iMac now I'll
show you a design that was done happy
with the double gate silicon nanowire
feeties on the device or again so this
again is projecting a library that will
implement this double gate devices and
these are the results that we eventually
get timing goes down by again a factor
of about sixteen percent but in this
case with an increase of areas and get
count why this is hard to say why but of
course you're pushing the envelope in
one direction very often you cannot
control it in the other direction but
still this is fairly interesting so let
me come to some key points again so the
first is that majority inverter grass
and the boolean algebra can push further
the capabilities of more modern logic
centers so the tools that we have today
the basic structure of these tools is
not the possible best structure that we
have the still innovation that can get
the results in a better way and there
are significant improvements on general
benchmarks but also for highly optimized
units like for example the device of 32
as compared to commercial tools and they
give support for emerging nanotechnology
libraries what is the next step the next
step is what sometimes I call the secret
weapon this has worked as a quick being
carried forward at FFL as collaboration
with other sites like Berkeley like the
group in Bremen and that relates to the
use of formal methods for doing exact
logic design and what is it well you can
take logic functions you can take a
library you can set up ways of
formulating the partners asset problem
and you
full Sat solver to see whether given a
network you can do another network with
a fewer number of gates
so this luckily has been done has been
published last year and there is a
fairly interesting results well it is
that of course you cannot do big
functions you can do functions that
relates for example two five six inputs
so what you will say well the networks
that we have today is are much bigger
well you can take a networking they
compose it in lookup tables for example
using kong endings algorithms well known
and then you will just optimize the best
network for the sub blocks and then you
can you check the results and you can
show that once you do placing Russ
you're still gaining compared to the
techniques that we have today
now the next step comes to the research
which is in progress that I cannot
describe in detail which relates doing
the same thing for delay now trying to
do exact synthesis for a function for
delay is more complicated because once
you have a block you not only you have
the function the library but also you
have the profile of the inputs that
arrive the DAC we can be an infinity of
configuration of the inputs that come in
so it's a question of actually
characterizing the problem in a smart
way so that you can come up with the
best implementation for a specific
profile of inputs and again how would
you do that in practice today you will
do it by decomposing a network into
blocks and then getting the best you
know implementation for timing and
stitching up the values part with the
hope that in the future with better
tools you can do them for networks that
are significant going from inputs to the
out think I've carved a lot of ground I
like just to come to some conclusions
first point is that emerging
technologies with enhanced functionality
devices like for example transistor
before inputs can increase the
computational density so it could be a
way equate to in parallel with scaling
back to be able to build systems that
are more performing and the other types
of constraint that can be manufacturing
concerning for example now as soon as
you get into this enhanced functionality
that touches the logic level then you
would need new design methods you design
tools in this verification that stem
from these new abstractions that is
something that has to be kept in mind
and the third point is that you have to
remember is that the current logic
synthesis has been today for CMOS is
based on specific heuristics there are
ways of improving these heuristics that
way by going to logic models that have
some properties like the reachability
property and eventually coming up to
methods that can be metadata exact in
solving that the path is still long but
computers are getting more and more
powerful and acqui techniques that were
unthinkable in the past like for example
solving exactly the two level logic
optimization problem and today's thing
that can be done for most of the
benchmarks of engineering interest I
like to close by thanking you for your
attention
thank you my sponsor which are the
European Research Council Yesi nano tier
as well as the Swiss National Science
Foundation and then especially thanking
these people which is my research group
the people who actually do the work and
while I'm travelling and giving talks
but it's a group that I enjoy very much
to work with so thank you
we have time for questions so with the
Spanish Alvia or availability of lyrical
majority were the majority tools are
available there is a set of tools that
are available on the on the necessaries
of where you're made available to the
research community and you complain pay
attention amazing piece of work we've
done here is put together the team
together working relatively small number
of years they're doing very interesting
work here when it's time flies I always
think that when I come here I just
sometimes I get to the airport is a I I
I got home it was driving to the hotel
basically I've been actually away for 12
years and is it really good for years
yes info yes time since I taught the
last to 71 in detail so you think you
think that there's going to be a shift
now towards X or a X or X who are logic
as opposed to you know more traditional
logic forms because of this I think it's
a very interesting thing to keep under
control because you know the work on
logic using exercise of all X goes back
you know to do more got to sow and
there's a lot of work be none of that
but it was always limited by the fact
that we were using CMOS biologic and now
the fact that we are bringing new types
of technologies that could be asked we
not only the future but a reasons for
these technologies to be because if
their new technology can implement the
same thing that you can do in CMOS most
likely because of one I'm motivating the
similans second because the design tools
and Vols are being perfected for CMOS in
this technology will never come up but
if you came into some parts I
computation in a better way just becomes
very interesting because in the end the
appetite that we have for
using you know it's like what if the
people they are never enough yes it's
going to be before we see you now - in
mass-produced commercial products well
from ownerships we have that expression
a different opinion
left and right
I'm dying to go first I'm trying to get
to get the gas I'm making my wife yeah
yeah for some extra products I think ok
we are in 17 I think we'll see Nana
washing bar you from from 20 to 25 with
the politician P for 25 - to 2030 ok so
ok I would say that will see the ma no
wires
yeah from 2020 to 2025 and the nanotubes
from 2025 to 2030 it's a while gas she
agrees what would be like the first
applications because it's no but we
massive a natural son I do increase in
one technology by another all well most
likely applications in and wire the
managers well the logic they are
different okay all right well not let me
try to answer it in a good way
their logic so they can provide if we
apply for general computing nanotubes
have the advantage that there could be
really a big step up in terms of speed
because the mo building side is much
better and if you really go to 3d
integration you know that see these are
ways of layering it up at lower
temperatures which makes it reasonable
because the CMOS like transistor has
been layered up like latias done it's
always tricky because of temperature you
can really have good beers yes we use
plankton whatever in the end you have
resistive part that kilobytes so there
you have romantic then there's the fact
that both
CNT
and nanowires are very good support for
sensors so if you have top layers of
systems where you have these Cyndi's or
nano wires which are functionalized in
order to be able to capture for example
biological agents or gases or other
chemicals this gives another reason why
doing them so let me put a thing in a
total different perspective if you go to
a hospital and at night with a
screwdriver as an engineer you open up
one of those boxes you know there's cost
a lot of money you will find out that
they look like transistor radios of the
60s you have all these discrete
components are put together there you
what the totally the highways like this
but the software is always like this
it's all proprietary software so if you
have something that goes out of money
you like a lot of the future there you
cannot do it because they will never let
you do it's a captive market there's a
big thing is to be able to bring in the
benefit of integration as we see to
integrate the same thing and the end the
computing part and suddenly the price
will drop and so you will have things
that will be applicable to do to the
white market there many wild ideas
because you know the market will not be
driven market sometimes is driven by
consumers you know they have been
application thoughts of having in all
senses on top of a cellphone so that
when somebody goes to the beach and puts
on a cream then you can act with skin it
and see if you're going to get a tan or
you're going to get you know skin cancer
or you don't get enough Sun so these are
applications hot click a very silly but
apparently driving the markets or the
fact of getting electronics that
combines the same thing that can be used
by many people but you know I'd also
dress analyzed that's where you have gas
sensors that can be combined very well
with TNT that can be very useful because
you at home you can just make a small
test and that's not only just to
convince your spouse that you didn't
come home drunk but it's also a way to
detect you know from this ballast or
something going on that could be bad so
I think that you know the these are the
things can lead to the switch of
paradigm
some other person disagrees with the
majority gates can in general more
efficient multiplier than others is that
yes absolutely
which of course you need to have
inversion but because that's basically
the underlying mechanism it's kind of a
distortion to take those kind of circuit
and then map them to man snores can we
also do some sort of multi-language
logic because you talk for now it's
still very ignorant well it's different
you know if you go to move the value
circuit typically abstract by algebra
that are not boolean but there are
trade-offs you know with versus levels
you know we can actually map some
multivalued problems in the world where
you have more inserts into majority that
could be a way to implement threshold
functions for it okay obviously a lot of
interest right now in building against
multiplier multiplied accumulator raise
for new kinds of so the my answer is I
related as to multivalued logic there I
don't ever
I would imagine that it it is very
interesting I would imagine that
underline of the by properties would be
different but really work investigation
I'm impossible okay whatever what about
talk dollars here we're reading in well
it's an unsolved problem in most spaces
but majority logic seems like it might
be very fault tolerant very sensitive
barriers not like an election that
majority fails
you have examples where that's okay but
in case it is this something which is
amenable to building systems that are
much more I guess anti Frenkel is the
right word because the not resilient but
where errors are at least not totally
destructive
I am the sender questions a good
question
probably it has to be made more specific
you know in order to to get an answer
and I don't have an answer handed on it
but I would tend to think intuitively
that if you have lots of data you
realize we rely on majority very often
that could be a way of aggregating data
and could be a way of tolerating some
knowledge of the data but we probably
your presence please done in two parts
well if you implement the cert with what
would be the poulterer's problem often
end node validation and inverter
majority implementation that's one thing
another one is a broader sense if you
have lots of data that comes in you have
reliability data improves it by
filtering to majority levels would that
be better or not and it may have been
only is better but I think that's
majority with simplification of
threshold is simplification of neural
soils we are all long dead lying yen for
analyzing data so that that's shown that
it can be very useful I suspect that is
a lot like it is currently that is with
a lot of thought you can make them much
more to learn
and there is a cost associated with that
and the need for it is generally not
found as we know
anybody else questions yes what's your
thought on cause some say that there is
no that no lack of a great ideas or
divided technologies going forward be a
cop don't kill us and stop any progress
there would be really made one comment
well I don't know my first thought is
that you know and it relates again to
merlot is that we will always have an
appetite for vendor computing so at some
point we are probably now at the cross
line that's scale well up to now people
who are scaled down and shown that they
still will make money and probably for a
while the words do but then the coasters
go on I think that's nature but I don't
think we will stop what would ever we
will say for example in the West and the
United States as well will give up
having the most powerful computers
because we don't want to pay for wafers
that more expensive I think even with
CMOS we will be forced to do it because
because a quick my opinion computing is
much more important any kind of weapon
also for defense this is one and then I
think the the interesting thing will be
if by looking at various technology any
of this will lead us to something that
less expensive to fabricate so to some
extent
anything which is basically based on you
know electrostatic doping Schottky
diodes and all that stuff avoid also
implantation and variability problems so
amazing some money
the none of wise that I've shown are
realizing a lab in a fab which are very
simple recipe relatively simple well of
course these are rosante these are not
you know competing with Intel's in
person once you get them vertical they
can be more complicated but I think it
really one catches that you know maybe
some new materials or new ways of doing
it will we lower the cost you know about
CMT's I don't know exactly what would be
D and you know that there's a standard
way that I've been way of doing that as
well your ways of doing that but it
doesn't necessarily to have to bring
more cost in the fabrication
that's wonderful
thank you
you